in the early formation of the solar
system when all the planets were being
formed Mars and Earth were actually
surprisingly similar Mars at one time
was once fertile temperate much like
Earth and something happened to it there
are massive a water erosion features
that are on Mars dating from its early
period the young Mars had rivers and
lakes it even had an ocean similar to
Earth and so in this period when life
originated on earth Mars was pretty
similar the solar wind blasted off Mars
is atmosphere and as the atmosphere went
further and further away and less and
less of the atmosphere remained then the
water started to have to boil off or
freeze and then it couldn't maintain its
temperature day to night quite as well
and it just caused a very very slow
change in its environment until it's
like it was today
Mars has the four critical elements that
you need for life carbon hydrogen oxygen
and nitrogen and it has them all in
abundance the gravity on Mars is less
than the earth so you know you'll have a
little bounce it'll be easier to move
around so it's roughly half the size of
Earth the surface of Mars has got about
the same amount of land as all the
continents of the earth put together
today on Mars is 24 hours in about 40
minutes and the year on Mars is about
two years on earth the sky is gonna be
red during the day and blue in the
evening and in the morning it has
unbelievable vistas it has some of the
tallest mountains in the solar system
certainly has the longest and deepest
valleys in the solar system Mars would
like to kill you in a number of exciting
ways first off it's very very cold the
warmest it gets is about zero Celsius
the average temperature I think is
around minus 50 minus 40 Celsius at the
equator on the warmest day you know it's
like Minnesota in the winter the rest of
the time it's like you know Antarctica
without any clothing Mars about half
again as far away from the Sun as the
earth is and so it's colder if you were
on the goal line of a football field and
the moon were one inch in front of you
Mars would be the other goal line that's
the scale of difference between how far
the moon is from Earth and how far Mars
is from Earth but if you think about it
in a more cosmic scale it's actually not
that far it's the next
we can do the trip to Mars using current
technology in six months it's a long
trip maybe not very different from the
trips that they're the pioneers you know
when they came to the West it typically
took them six to nine months the biggest
issue by far is the pressure on Mars
atmosphere is very very thin so that
means the pressure on Mars is about 1%
of pressure on earth that's about the
equivalent that's if you're flowing at
30,000 feet you'd have to have a hole
you'd have to have something to keep the
pressure in for your civilization it's
about as hostile and environment as you
can think of except possibly for deep
space